the voice is welcoming a brand new judge
for the upcoming 22nd season with
camilla cabello joining the likes of
blake shelton gwen stefani and john
legend that's right but of course before
hitting the chair camila needed to turn
to her fellow coaches for a little
advice take a look take care everyone
thanks for joining us bye
what do you guys love about being on the
show you're always happy when it gets to
the lives and it's out of your hands at
that point the hardest part is
definitely sending people home because
you went through all of that to get them
on your team i have no doubt in my mind
that i would be a great coach for you no
don
no
okay so what do you guys think is the
number one thing
that you need to be a good coach
i think you have to love music you still
have to have like inspiration and joy in
music yeah yeah yeah i feel like this
show helps me keep that going it's a lot
of creativity yeah because i i feel like
you meet all these young artists that
are hungry and like really want to make
it in our business that we've been in
for a long time and it like renews my
inspiration i think the willingness to
be real with those contestants or
artists on your team because it's real
easy to just play to the camera and say
what you think is
good for the show but it's it's hard to
look at someone in my eye and
and say man i'm just telling you right
now you know whatever the bad news is
you know what i mean not and not worry
about coming across how you're gonna
come across on tv this is gonna be a
really fun season we're excited i'm
really excited you're so cute you're so
smart you're witty you're really good at
beating up blake and funny yeah hey this
is so fun